翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Eriko T
みなさん こんにちは
熊本県知事の蒲島です
本当は 安田講堂でみなさんに
お会いしたかったんですけど
今 熊本は震災対応で大変なんです
そこで 熊本から喋らせていただきます
今日はみなさんに
二つのことをお話したいと思います
一つは 私の人生から得られた経験で
「逆境の中にこそ夢がある」
これが第１
第２番目は 私が知事になって
政治について感じたこと
「政治とは何か？」
この二つについて お話ししたいと思います
私が生まれたのは 1947年です
稲田村という小さな村の
農家の生まれです
そして ９人兄弟の７番目で
とても家が貧乏だったものですから
高校まで 家計を助けるために
新聞配達をしました
米のご飯を食べられたのは
なんと 年に２回ほどなんです
そういう所で育って また高校にも —
地方の高校に行きましたけれども
私は220番中の200番台で卒業しました
ほとんど ビリで卒業したんです
私には３つの大きな夢がありました
１つの夢が 阿蘇で牧場を開くことです
２番目の夢が
私が将来は 政治家になりたいという夢です
３番目の夢が
小説家になりたいという夢がありました
高校を卒業して 稲田村農協に勤めました
しかし 二十歳のときに
どうしても将来は牧場を開きたいということで
アメリカに農業青年を送る
派米農業研修生のプログラムに応募しました
そして21歳のときに農業研修生として
アメリカに２年間渡ったんです
農業はとても大変だったんです
でも １つだけ良かったのは
ネブラスカ大学という所で
学科研修が３ヶ月間だけありました
そのときに初めて勉強して
「なんと 学問は 農業と比べると楽だろう」
と思って
またアメリカに戻りたくなりました
24歳のときに アメリカに戻って
ネブラスカ大学に留学しました
私が入学したのは
大学の農学部の繁殖生理学というところです
そこで私が研究したのは
ブタの精子の保存方法の研究です
28歳のときに卒業するときに
私の指導教授が 「大学に残らないか？」
と言ってくれました
大学に残るということは
一生勉強することですから
一生勉強するんだったら
本当にやりたいことが勉強したい
ということで
「何をやりたいか？」と考えたら
「昔 夢見た 政治を勉強したい 」
と思うようになったんです
「政治を勉強するんだったら
ハーバード大学だ」ということで
ハーバード大学の大学院に入りました
32歳のときに博士号を取って
そして日本に帰り
つくば大学で17年間
東京大学法学部で11年間 勤めた後
2008年に熊本県知事の選挙に出ました
今は熊本県知事として
仕事をしています
そして 県知事として感じたことは
「政治とは何か？」ということです
政治には３つの側面があります
１つの側面は
「決断すること」
２番目が
「目標を達成すること」
３番目が さまざまな場面に
どのように対応するかという
「対応の政治」です
まず第１の「決断の政治」
私が2008年の９月の11日に
川辺川ダムを作らないという決断をしました
これは日本で初めて
川辺川ダムのような 大工事が中止された事は
多分日本の歴史では無かったでしょう
そのためには ですね
精神の自由が必要です
さまざまなプレッシャーがかかります
でも 精神の自由を以って
この川辺川ダムの
白紙撤回を表明しました
２番目の「目標の政治」
これについては
熊本県民の私が目標としているのは
「幸福量の最大化」です
熊本県民が幸福になることを
私は常に願いながら 知事をやっています
この幸福量に４つの大きな要因があります
１つは経済的な要因
２番目にプライド
３番目が安心安全のセキュリティ、Sですね
４番目がホープ、夢です
例えば この目標を達成するために
熊本県民を幸せにするために
出した政策の１つが
くまモンの政策です
くまモンはなんと —
この経済効果は抜群であります
例えば 平成23年の
くまモン関連の売り上げが25億円
そして 平成27年の
くまモン関連の売り上げが
１千億を超えて
１千７億円になりました
だから くまモンは熊本県に
多大な経済的な寄与をしています
そして２番目の「プライド」も
くまモンがいることによって
熊本県民はとても誇りに思っています
３番目の「安心、安全」
これについては１つ
これはあの 「おしゃべりくまモン」なんです
この「おしゃべりくまモン」を
老人介護施設に配っています
そして そこに入所されているお年寄りの方は
くまモンと話すことによって
とても喜びを感じています
「くまモン」
（おしゃべりくまモン）
「くまモン元気ですか？」
（くまモン）くまモン 元気ですか？
「くまモンは …」
（くまモン）くまモンは…
くまモンは電池がある限り
ずっとしゃべり続けます
（くまモン）ずっとしゃべり続けます
お年寄りはくまモンとしゃべることを
とても喜んでいます
（くまモン）お年寄りは
くまモンとしゃべることをとても喜んでいます
「くまモン 今日は東京から
みんな聞いているよ」
（くまモン）くまモン 今日は
東京からみんな聞いているよ
このような働きもしています
（くまモン）このような働きもしています
はいありがとう
（くまモン）はいありがとう
そして最後４が「夢」です
くまモンは熊本県民に
多くの夢を与えてくれています
そういう意味では
くまモンは普通の政策ではないけれども
熊本県民を幸せにするという
そういう意味での
立派な政策ではないでしょうか？
私は県庁の職員の方々に
第２のくまモンを探そうと言っています
それはくまモンを作るのではなくて
くまモンのように
政策が経済的な効果がある
人々が誇りに思えるような政策を作る
そして３番目に
安心安全に貢献するような政策
４番目が 夢につながるような政策を
作って欲しい ということで
それが「目標の政治」の１つであります
３番目 「対応の政治」
これは 政治をやっていると
何が起こるか分かりません
今年の４月の14日に なんと
阪神大震災と同じくらい —
震度７の地震が熊本県に来ました
そして 28時間後
これは４月の16日に
その１回目よりも大きい
震度７以上の地震が熊本を襲ったんです
熊本の人口の約10％という
18万人の方が
避難所に逃げてきました
この方々に避難所を用意し
食料を用意し 水を用意し
そしてだんだんだんだん
さまざまな形で
その方々に住宅を用意すると
そういうことが必要になってきています
この震災に対応するために
我々は３つの原則で進んでいます
１つは被害に遭われた方々の痛みを最小化する
そのために 木造で仮設住宅を作ったり
仮設住宅の真ん中に集会所を作ったりして
痛みを最小化しています
２番目は 単なる元に戻すだけじゃなくて
創造的な復興をしよう と
これが ２番目の目標です
３番目の目標が この—
復旧復興を
熊本の更なる発展につなげようと
これは私の最初のメッセージである —
「逆境の中にこそ夢がある」
から来ています
今 熊本はとても逆境にあります
しかしこれを乗り越えて
創造的な復興をすること —
これを乗り越えて更に熊本が発展すること —
これによって 今まで以上に
熊本県民の幸せ度は
高まるんじゃないかなと思っています
みなさんにお願いがあります
今 スクリーンに映っているように
熊本城がとても傷んでいます
ぜひボランティアと
ボランティアになったつもりで
熊本に旅行に来ていただき
そしてこの熊本の今の姿を見ていただき
そして10年後はどうなっているか？
というのをみなさんの目で確かめて欲しい
10年後にはこの傷んだ熊本城が
きっときれいに再生していると思っています
それこそ 「逆境の中にこそ夢がある」
これを政策で実現することであります
どうぞ熊本に旅行に来ることが
ボランティアだと思って
旅行ボランティアをやってください
よろしくお願いします
ありがとうございます